You have said that the only moral
absolute is always to tell the truth.
What if you have Anne frank and the attic
and the gifts Stapel at your on your
doorstep.
Then I would say that there has been a
lot of lies that have got you to that
point.
So you may be in a situation where you're
damned if you turn right and you're
damned if you turn left.
And what that means is you made
a lot of mistakes along the way.
You know,
so if the totalitarians
or knocking at your door,
if the totalitarians or
knocking on everyone's door,
that means everyone should
have spoke up a lot sooner.
And then they wouldn't end
up in a situation where the
Gestapo was out the door
and Anne Frank was in the
owl is it was in the attic.
So you'd now,
and then you end up in a situation where
you've made so many mistakes that all
you've got is hell around you.
And that was certainly
the case in Amsterdam say,
or an in,
in when the Nazis came in on,
I mean the Dutch and admirable people,
and I know they were invaded by the
Nazis and that was a terrible thing,
but many,
many,
many people made many terrible moral
errors for all of that to occur.
And you have to be awake and do everything
you can to make sure your society
doesn't,
this is the answer.
You be away.
Can you make sure everything you society
does doesn't lead to the point where
the Gestapo is at your doorstep and
you have Anne Frank in the attic.
It's a little late to be
thinking then I would say.